a day until the long-awaited
by-elections in wakefield in yorkshire
and tibetan and hunterton in devon it
was a rowdy pm cues with both kierstarma
and boris johnson keen to get in their
pre-election pitch
it's crashed the economy he's put
everybody's tax up the last tory sent up
to wakefield being convicted of a sexual
assault that's not much of a pitch prime
minister people of this country and the
people of wakefield people of tibetan
and hollister would much rather vote uh
for a solid conservative government
[Music]
for a labor party there are enablers and
acolytes in the liberal democrats mr
speaker the chameleons the karma
chameleons of british politics
before the pitch though came the punchy
first question from labour's chris
elmore about claims carrie johnson was
offered a top job in the foreign office
prime minister
have has he ever considered the
appointment
of his current spouse
to a government post or to any
organization yes in one of the royal
households i know why the uh the party
opposite wants to talk about
non-existent jobs in the in the media mr
speaker because they don't want to talk
about what's going on in the real world
last week the labour leader was
criticized for avoiding big divisive
issues like the rail strikes this week
he engaged when the pm accused labour of
backing the strikes
the prime minister of this country and
his transport secretary haven't attended
a single meeting held a conversation or
lifted a finger to stop these strikes
the reason his authority is on the line
in this matter is that they take
they take 10 million pounds from the
unions he's standing with the strikers
mr speaker and lifting the cost of
transport for everybody that's the
reality
kirstarma's questions this week were
focused on the economy and strikes our
analysis of his language shows that the
word he used most was pay he also used
words like wakefield bankers people cut
government
the prime minister used words like
pounds country and railways boris
johnson knows the strikes are tricky
ground for labour and there was a
notable absence behind the speaker's
chair today yesterday labour whip nav
mishra disobeyed kirstama's order that
his front bench shouldn't join the
picket line today he was missing from
his usual spot if he is genuine
meanwhile on the tory benches plenty of
cheering and pointing unity on the
subject of industrial action
and from the great government critic the
smpz and blackford a muted appearance
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself can i associate myself with the
remarks of the prime minister
his first pmq's since apologizing for
backing a colleague suspended for sexual
misconduct the prime minister though was
keen at any opportunity to steer onto
rail strikes when is he going to stop
meaningless sound bites and instead
start supporting working people across
our country
if she if she wants to support the
working people of this country mr
speaker can i suggest she gets off the
picket line
a sum of strikes could mean political
pain for labour but widespread commuter
misery isn't good for the government
either for now though all eyes are on
two very different long awaited
by-elections tomorrow
you